the jurgen experience
save texas yeah people are really
worried about all folks like me
moving from uh california yeah
worried they're worried about you know
what's funny is that we want we will
come one come all
give me your tired your poor come on to
texas but you got to understand
something
yeah you're coming here because of low
taxes and low regulation and you want to
live your life in liberty
and make sure that you can protect
yourself and protect your family
and that means you have to you have to
vote a certain way and
that's why we kind of r texas don't
turn this place into what you fled
that's exactly right yeah that's what
matthew mcconaughey was telling that's
exactly right
and we have to kind of put that out
there to people all right and i
understand people have different views
and whatnot but you're here for a reason
yeah well the thing is you can be
socially liberal
yes but also understand that there's
there's certain things that are just
not wise yes and a lot of those things
are ruining
california that's right there's there's
over regulation in california that's
taxes off the [ __ ] truck
the tax the taxes are so crazy there and
they're trying to raise them up to 16.8
percent
and then what are you going to do with
that money [ __ ] it up worse you have
more money to [ __ ] things up
i just don't understand their logic of
of opening and not opening things
and especially now when you look at the
deaths
like when they want to talk about covet
cases the cases are low
they're not that high and the deaths are
very low it's like we it's
we've kind of got a handle on what this
is you can let people open up their
businesses
so you can let people wear masks and be
careful and take care of themselves and
take vitamin d and zinc and vitamin c
and we can we can at least get back to
some
semblance of normality that's right but
they don't want to do that for some
weird reason and
this is the one that drives me crazy
they keep saying after the election
yeah they're not even trying to hide the
fact that they're politicizing this like
they won't let kids go back to school in
california until
after the election like what the [ __ ]
does the election have to do with
anything
how is that scientific like how is
november 3rd how is that
your science point it's not
again this is what makes texas texas
we just believe in liberty yes we
believe in allowing and empowering the
citizens to make your own personal
informed decisions for your own life yes
if you want to take the risk
then then we allow you to do so go buy a
tiger
how did you know i was going to say that
you know the statistic about tigers here
what there's more tigers in captivity in
texas than all of the wild of the world
i did not know that there's more tigers
in private collections in texas
in texas than all of the wild of the
planet earth
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love